bon alors maintenant comme vous voyez
c'est sans rien sans maquillage
peut-être qu'il en reste encore un petit
peu c'est jamais écrit un pinson les
petits tampons pour nettoyer son des
tambours cinq noms sont des tampons un
peu humide c'est toi bien les paupières
on en profite pour retrousser les cils
voilà quand tout est propre prend du
temps
quand tout est propre on regarde un peu
et on cherche
qu'est-ce que ses gommes crayons à ça
c'est un crayon gris qui va me servir à
creuser davantage la paupière comme j'ai
les yeux un peu à fleur de peau il faut
donner une impression de profondeur avec
un crayon gris que j'étale sur toute la
paupière et spécialement le long de la
paupière supérieure pour donner beaucoup
plus de profondeur
la même chose de l'autre côté
maintenant on va faire un travail de
balayette pour estomper tout ça qui est
très très dur jusqu'à ce que ça devienne
d'un gris d'un gris moyen un peu plus
foncé sur le super et sur le rôle à la
comme on appelle ça sur le dans le creux
de la paupière supérieure
enfin oui c'est ça elle met le doigt
ça aide il sort les soirées stomp un peu
de façon à ce que tous ce soir d'une
couleur tout sauf agressive en étant un
peu sur les côtés pour allonger l'oeil
de vincennes beaucoup peuplèrent nature
et oui c'est vrai j'ai tenu que ça fasse
y penser on met tout de suite leurs
emails
je passais très orthodoxe ma façon de la
mer commencer par le bout des cils et
puis progressivement fin j'étais pressé
par le temps
bon l'opération rimmel terminé on prend
un petit bâtonnet qui est enduit d'une
poudre gris bleuté qui a surtout un
avantage cdh est une couleur très
seyante pour eux pour les yeux et un
deuxième avantage c'est assez pour le
bord de la mer
c'est que ça ne bouge pas ça ne coule
pas
quand l'opération est terminée à
l'intérieur de l'oeil des deux côtés on
attaque la paupière supérieure de la
même façon c'est pas d'importance il ya
pas un trait qui soit bien fait bien
délimités au contraire quand tout ça est
fini on attaque le sourcil toujours au
crayon gris tout est pris tout et tout
et gray sauf ce trek je fais en ce
moment qui est une couleur bistre et
marron là j'en fus en dessous parce que
janet public l'autre je fais ce monde
d'un côté et ceux très marron bistre et
qui les creuse davantage ce que c'est
vrai on a l'impression que c'est très
très très foncé alors qu'au naturel se
voit pas tellement redessine bien ce
bessin voilà la chose fini
je n'ai pas l'air gai mais vous savez ce
n'est pas ça ne fait pas mal
[Musique]